the basic idea we're exploring is what
makes people advocate or share their
opinions with other people
and one fact that we examine in this
research is whether people believe that
other people's attitudes are fixed or
changing so some people believe that
your opinions are your opinions and
there's nothing you can do about them
like you may like sauerkraut or you may
hate it and there's nothing you can do
to change that and other people think
that attitudes are very variable and
they can change over time and so we
examined how these beliefs affect
people's likelihood of sharing their
opinions with others so as it turns out
each theory can have factors that make
you more likely to try to persuade other
people if I believe that attitudes are
stable over time I have greater
certainty about my own attitudes I think
my own attitudes will remain the same
over time and that makes me have more
conviction in those attitudes and when I
have more conviction in those attitudes
that makes me more likely to try to
persuade other people on the other hand
theories that attitudes are malleable
can also increase advocacy if I believe
that attitudes can change over time I'm
more likely to believe that your
attitudes can change and therefore I'm
more likely to try to persuade you
so if I know what type of theory you
hold if you have a theory that attitudes
are malleable for example and what I
want to do is promote that focus on
other people to focus on how other
people's attitudes can be changed and
that will increase your likelihood of
trying to persuade other people whereas
if I know that you hold an attitude of
stability then I want to direct your
focus to the stability of your own
attitudes which will give you greater
conviction in those attitudes and be
more likely to try to persuade other
people these days there's more and more
what marketers called media clutter lots
and lots of advertisers are clamoring
for the same limited bandwidth of
attention that consumers have and also
consumers are increasingly skeptical of
advertising efforts and so one
particularly effective form of
persuading other people is through
communications through trusted friends
and and loved ones
and so to the extent that we can get
people to share their opinions with
other people particularly for topics
that they may be reluctant to do so such
as political things we can increase the
likelihood that we will be able to bring
people around to to our desired point of
view